how are you
oh good ted turner doesn't like you
nor does his stuff buffalo
uh so good to see you thanks for being
here thank you you helped us out a
little bit we did the other night on the
show and i thank you for you became don
draper for us which was very cool it was
really fun yeah it was a lot of fun and
i don't you know it's just i
i said you in the bid you're a very
handsome man i don't know is this thing
that you've been cursed with all your
life or were you an awkward person who
suddenly turned into jon hamm
later in life still tremendously awkward
yes uh but uh
yeah you know it's uh it's funny when
they put very fancy clothes on you and
uh you have 400 people attending to your
hair and makeup how handsome you can all
of a sudden become i have not found that
to be true
we have people working on me with
hydraulic machinery
for hours it's like oh you're miracle
um
i'm curious about something which is uh
i'm a big fan of mad men my wife and i
watch this show religiously i have seen
every single episode and uh you're
terrific on the show
there's not a lot of strenuous physical
activity no playing don draper there's a
lot of drinking sitting uh crossing a
room and then i find out that you have
been hurt
you've been physically hurt
several times playing don draper how is
that possible i've i've gone to the
hospital twice
uh the first season uh a piece of the
set fell on my head
i shouldn't laugh i'm sorry
to be fair it was pretty funny yeah
just a piece of the set fell huge part
of the wall fell hit me right on the
head i started bleeding
i had seven stitches in my head uh
season two yeah yeah i know it's pretty
sad yeah um oh the ladies are loving
this
[Music]
uh oh he's hurt
uh and the second season uh in a one of
the flashbacks to the to the war there
was an explosion and i had to sort of
jump through the thing and i broke my
hand and and on the rehearsal and then
when we shot it i separated my shoulder
really
my goodness okay so you actually have
these stunts now
i'm curious what happens when you when
you break a hand your character of
course can't be wearing a cast what do
they do uh no i had a i had sort of a
removable cast and it was fortunate
toward the end of the of the show so i
would just take the cast off when we
were shooting warn everybody broken hand
like don't don't touch my hand please
don't like
hilariously punch me in the hand or
that old bit we all love to do a lot of
hand punching yeah in the 60s it was big
it was really big yeah uh
but uh there was
there was a scene where i i promote the
uh my secretary to copywriter and she
sort of forthrightly puts her hand out
and shakes my hand and i had elizabeth
moss and i had warned her i was like you
know my hand is actually physically
broken
uh and it's
very remarkably painful
so if you when we do the scene could you
just kind of you know don't squeeze it
when you shake it uh she apparently
thought i was kidding
uh
and uh when we shot the uh actually shot
it uh gave me like the full-on
congratulations handshake and i i
literally went to my knees i was like ah
you shrieked i shrieked like a girl
went i've hit my knees and she was
mortified and uh and it was the most
painful experience i've ever been
through in my life and her excuse was
just like i thought it was a joke i
thought you were kidding yeah tough suck
it up
she's a tough guy yeah is that on film
yeah because i bet that's funny you
might want to check the dvd extras
because i'm sure somewhere some
post-production supervisor has that has
it and
you know it's funny uh you see all kinds
of weird things on the internet and uh
and yes
yeah and we have you uh having sex uh
what's taking no uh
i mean
there's so many ways to go when you
start off with you see so many
interesting things on the internet well
uh there's someone has made a montage of
all the different ways that don draper
says what
and uh
it's quite fascinating and i don't know
if you've seen it yet
i haven't
let's take a look okay
what
what
what
what
what
what
what
what what what
what
what
what
a two-minute acting class right there
acting class right there there are a lot
of ways to say what apparently yeah um i
was curious uh i've noticed on the show
that uh occasionally the show will move
uh relatively slowly through time and
then there are other times where you'll
skip ahead as much as maybe a year or
two years i think you're at around 1965
now
yes we uh we ended this this season uh
at the end of 1965. which was
interesting to me i don't know if other
viewers have thought about this but as
the show goes on it's very popular and
it's clearly going to keep running for a
while
we're coming quickly towards the late
60s early 70s when i mean there is a mr
brady brady bunch
hair perm in your life or some you know
giant ties
there are very uncool clothing styles
coming up they certainly are what are
you gonna do we're gonna end the show
i am not putting a nero jacket on
there's a big porno mustache coming up
there's going to be no fringe
so that's just when you're going to walk
out away make sure that's in your
contract oh yeah well well there's
contracts how about that no i uh i i
i will not be uh i will not be uh
wearing the 70s fashions i think is don
draper okay good i don't want to see
that and it's important and what i say
goes in this town clearly uh
but uh you know i keep hearing a rumor
which is they say there's going to be a
new superman movie
and your name keeps coming up which and
i thought
you'd make a great superman everyone
wants to see a middle-aged superman
with the with the power of of
handicapped parking
mall walking
a superman who's struggling with some
issues sure what's wrong with that
superman with like you know who had to
buy a fast car
that makes no sense david you know dated
a younger woman to make him feel alive
yeah
i like that he's superman and he has to
get a porsche you know
he can fly to mars in a second but he
needs a car that can go 80 miles an hour
on the freeway feel that good about
himself
hit a certain age he's not so super
anymore yeah we're just super kids
everywhere taking his
super
publicity
you can't put super in front of any
words super certainly can
[Laughter]
yes you can you're jon hamm
uh you have been uh very kind to me i am
so thrilled that you were able to be
here this uh first week we're huge fans
uh jon hamm thank you so much for being
here
he's a good man we'll be right back
you